let's talk about colleges I want to talk
about the story we got here from uh
Daily Mail University of California
Santa Barbara's black student union
holds free black panther wakanda forever
screening but asks white students not to
attend
oh yes this is what they mean by
diversity racial segregation
so uh there's another article from the
Philadelphia Inquirer that was talking
about the writer was Mexican and he was
saying how you know he didn't understand
Black Panther and what it meant for the
black community seeing an African
country that wasn't devastated by
colonization and then he was like and
then I saw no more and and nutello Khan
in wakanda forever and then I started to
understand and I'm just thinking like
these woke people
their view of what is good in terms of
racial like racial ideology is
stereotypes of races totally segregated
and fighting with each other that was
the craziest thing like black panther
have you seen it oh hell no well why not
thank you why not I I love comic books I
like Namor by the way so I have no
interest in Namor is that how it's
pronounced now okay well not not for my
entire life of reading Marvel Comics but
what I don't think I'm supposed to roll
the Arabic well I don't know they've
changed it and so exactly I have no I
mean my character's gotta I'm not
Daredevil shirt which is not from a
particularly good run on Daredevil by
Mark Wade but um I have no interest in
modern Comics because they had no
interest in me what what don't you like
about Black Panther
I thought the first movie was okay yeah
but it was like it was it was like it
was crazy it was a good I like it was a
good movie but I just I don't I didn't
watch any of this stuff was a wakanda
first close right which was bizarre that
they did make him a a you know wakanda
nationalist I'm gonna spoil it I mean
I've already spoiled it a million times
but you see this is this is Judge in a
book by by its cover wakanda forever the
point I'm making about how racist this
is is a movie quite literally about the
most powerful Nation on Earth so says
Queen ramonda with a powerful barrier
around their country that no one can
breach and a Mexican guy breaks in by
crossing a river oh I I've lost your
video about it earlier sorry I've heard
some other people talk about it so I I'm
aware of what happens in the film it's
and they're cheering for it they're like
this is the greatest movie and it's
funny because we had Dave Landau here
and when we were talking about it before
the show and I explained it's a Mexican
guy and his back you know as he climbs
out of the river is wet and I said how
do you think they defeat him and he goes
do they dry him off and I was like yes
yes and he was like so it's the greatest
movie ever right yeah stereotypes are a
simple way of understanding the world
and that it's also something called a
cognitive heuristic we all rely on
cognitive heuristics as mental shortcuts
so for example if you see a stick in the
grass we have evolved to very quickly
make a snap judgment to decide if that
is a stick in the grass or a snake it
reduces cognitive load to rely upon
stereotypes it literally means you have
to think less they expend less mental
energy so people like stereotypes for
that reason so I think that maybe in
some way they're just like oh I don't
have to I can turn my brain off even
more during this Marvel movie than I
usually would because I can just rely
upon stereotypes about other people now
now that we've we've entertained that
and we talked about it before I have
this story from indiewire John Leguizamo
calls out non-diverse Super Mario
Brothers casting it's going backwards
for them to go backwards and not cast
another actor of color kind of sucks
like wazama who star the 1993
live-action version of the upcoming
animated movie let me just explain this
very simply Mario and Luigi are two
white plumbers John Leguizamo is angry
that two white guys were cast to play as
white plumbers this is the extent of
wokeness in in
culture it sounds like they're making
the like far right position or argument
that Italians aren't White
that's what that's what I was thinking
too like uh that's really weird it is
bizarre It's News to the white Italians
but I've seen that like like very far
right people will say because of
um
proximity to Africa that Italians aren't
really white if that's what you're
saying then I mean okay well like you
and Richard Spencer can be buddies but
here's here's the thing you want to know
what this is really about John Leguizamo
played Luigi in 1993 right and he wants
to play Luigi now it's a big role it's
big money and he's mad they're not
casting him so he makes it about race
and says it's going backwards bro if the
argument is that people should only play
characters that are their race then you
should be happy that white actors were
cast to play White characters the the
concern was when you had black
characters voiced by white people
no apparently now the concern is for the
the entire time all these people ever
really cared about was empowering
themselves and making money as the only
person of color here in this room I
think it's I think every Studio should
follow Netflix's uh protocol and make
you know all the characters uh as
diverse as they possibly can no matter
how ridiculous or absurd it is and the
memes are absolutely hilarious too
the book says that they cut the white
bread and it's a piece of France I
tweeted that one today too uh but yeah
this is just just people going crazy I
think this is just something
highlighting our our mental health
decline I think a lot of people aren't
well I think this is a perfect example
of it and I think this kind of uh
regurgitation of nonsense is just
becoming more and more normalized and
there's some woke companies that
actually follow these principles which
is absolutely absurd uh it's stupid it's
discriminatory it's racist it's
ridiculous I mean I think part of it is
that the implication is that white
people are meant to be secondary or
replaceable I think part of it is you
know to compensate the when I was in
college what I heard regularly was that
because white people have
traditionally held institution of power
it's not even that you need to have
representation you need to have over
representation to compensate right so we
can't have white Italian plumbers
because they should have always been
diverse to make up for the fact like
it's such a trap and at the end of it
you just hear that white culture is not
real and fake like I am sure you could
get an Italian actor what was the uh the
mayor of La he was like I I am diverse
because I am Italian I identify with the
Latino Community like excuse me what
like there is such an interest in
divorcing yourself from Western European
culture of course if you can grab at
some kind of power and I think that's
because we're repeatedly told that it's
supposed to be a race we're not supposed
to see it anymore we'll just make up for
wrongs from the past yes that's where
you get the Rachel dolezels right of I'm
gonna essentially you know
play at a Minstrel show because this is
how I gain institutional power by
pretending that I'm I'm anything but
white like how come X and talcum or Luke
hey hey I'm officially recognized I got
the paperwork to prove it but watch out
Tim from where where did you get people
how many people are people of color
exactly yeah listen here Helen Claire
don't you challenge me
right that's racist completely the
non-minority in the room I'm just gonna
say it I'm you're the whitest person in
this room all right you should not have
a voice here I don't know what surge is
doing over here that's true he's second
in line and I speak first as the
dominant wife's voice in this room no
I'm just kidding but I I mean I think
this is this strange white guilt that we
see cultivated that it's it's
um like he thinks someone will clap him
on the back he'll get this and be a
write-up because he I mean I don't know
maybe this guy is super relevant maybe
we hear from him all the time not
recently right so the only time he
surfaces when he can denounce casting
white people like that seems like a
weird yeah it seems terrible well who's
who's gonna
um say anything against him in the
mainstream media nobody this is he's
just he'll just get applauded for this
that's the main issue he worries about
how privileged does he have to be how
how lucky does he have to be to live in
a world where this is his major issue
this is what he decides to to Rally
behind there's so much economic
inequality there's so much horrible
things happening with our health there's
so much corruption within our political
system there's so many multinational
corporations and big Banks screwing
everyone over and this is what your main
issue is come on man I wonder what
compelled him to star in the past you
ever see that movie no nobody knows that
reference oh man it probably means
I would say to counter your point though
Luke just a little bit media and culture
do actually matter which is why it's
cool that you guys are doing so much of
what you are doing and I think that
they're aware of that and that's why he
made the comment that he did because he
is aware on some level that media and
call culture does matter and so he has
to make his weird I'm just going to
virtually statement I'm I'm bringing up
this movie as kind of a dig against him
because like if he wants to act out I'm
gonna mention that he starred in the
film The Pest which is like a really
really bad late 90s movie that cost
eight million dollars and only made 3.6
so uh what's the plot man I don't
remember was it diverse though I guess
he's like did he take a spot away from
me yeah that's that is the operative
question he gets hunted for sport or
something
because he's white that would be like
you could make that yeah today that
would be the funny thing is like
apparently there's this this issue
because he claims he's Puerto Rican John
Leguizamo his dad came out he's like
he's Colombian okay there was a movie
about that I thought that came out about
a white family being hunted not that
long ago there was that actually it was
really good uh the Hunt is that it yeah
like everyone thought the movie was
explicitly just like conservatives being
hunted oh yeah yeah the film was
actually a bit more nuanced than that
and actually was pretty good yeah I
didn't I didn't see it the Liberals were
the bad guys oh okay yeah like outright
just really stupid and evil and they end
up
I'll give you I'll spoil it for
everybody because I think it's been out
for a few years it's probably okay so
the trailer made it seem like
conservatives get hunted by liberals
you watch the film the Liberals are
clearly the villains and they kidnap
incorrectly some woman because they had
bad information so not only were they
evil for trying to hunt and kill like
middle Americans who just have to be
conservative the main character happens
to have been incorrectly kidnapped and
they try murdering her and then in the
end even though the woman knows like
whoops you're trying to kill an innocent
person the liberal man still wants to so
it's like they're outright just the bad
guys so I was like actually you know do
you think the people who saw that movie
were able to catch on to the message
they're explicitly the bad guys it's
like she's that doesn't necessarily mean
people understood it so it's like she's
her and her friends I mean I think it
was well done her she's driving a text
group and then someone posts a joke
about eating babies or something and
then it gets leaked and then a
conspiracy theory forms about it so they
decide they're going to murder it
they're going to kidnap and murder
anyone who believes the conspiracy they
end up grabbing a woman of the same name
as someone else online she's totally
innocent and has nothing to do with
anything it's not political at all and
then and she ends up killing them all so
like I think it was actually well done
she's like you got the wrong person I
don't care about any of this she's like
I just want to go home but you know I
thought it was uh I actually thought it
was maybe the criticism still stands
like at a time when there's as much
political division we shouldn't put out
movies that are like that but it was not
a movie where the message overtly was
haha go hunt and kill conservatives
but that's what the trailer made it look
like so maybe they could have done a
better job right yeah
could act in part two of that there you
go there you go here's a job for you
yeah but they got everyone talking about
it so they got everyone right no they
canceled it remember though like they
they yeah they they pulled it and then
then later on they said okay we're gonna
bring the movie back yeah I don't
remember that part of it I remember
hearing about it even Trump was tweeting
about it what better way to promote a
movie than have the president of the
United States tweet at it well now he
can't do that anymore is the verb truth
he truth he truths I believe yeah yeah
look trumpet it originally was going to
be September 27th and then they said
they were canceling and then later they
brought it back March 13th
yeah
yeah it made money 14 million dollar
budget 42.8 million dollar Revenue well
yeah again the the tactic worked then
for one one reason or another
yeah
there you go
anyway
a bit of an aside yeah as an aside uh
watch the movie there you go what other
movies should we watch
um going to the weekend what are your
recommendations going into the weekend
uh it's it's it's uh wakanda forever
obviously because it's funny how the
woke people are like yeah this would be
so good and I'm like this movie is like
super yeah it's it's but but like so the
first problem with the first one was the
first one the first but it was the first
one was a a
patriarchal
Ultra nationalist country
ethnocentric ethno ethnonationalist
in order to rule you had to win trial by
combat and be a man women weren't
allowed to rule
and then the villain was basically an
ethno supremacist who wanted to use the
superior weapons to take over the world
for their race it's like that's an
interesting narrative it was the good
guy was Trump the bad guy was Hitler and
then you have part two where this
powerful Nation wants to mind its own
business and then Mexicans are crossing
through the river into the country
wreaking havoc I'm like who are they
making this movie for who is the writer
for this movie I need to know who was
sitting there like uh-huh okay and what
should we do next okay we shouldn't have
Namor be Atlantean because of copyright
issues let's have him be Mexican and
then he breaks into wakanda for some
reason a landlocked Nation by crossing
the border wall no no like I don't know
what it is oh that's funny it was over
copyright reasons that he couldn't be
from Atlantis they I guess the issue was
uh Brett from pop culture crisis was
telling me this that uh they didn't want
to pay the original Creator or like his
estate so by substantively changing
Neymar to Namor which was uh he was the
child without love right so in Spanish
she was like my enemies call me Namor oh
it's like okay dude no your enemies
don't call you that one guy called you
that 500 years ago you're cringing over
there yeah that's all I didn't unders I
didn't know about that part but this is
why I don't watch these movies and I
don't watch I don't watch what is it
rings of power I will watch
um
other people on YouTube do five hour
long reviews of them for sure because I
find that entertaining I have to imagine
though with like black panther you'll
end up with white identitarians and the
woke editorians sitting in the theater
together cheering for the same messages
I saw that with the first one on you
know like the four on 4chan when the
first one came out there were people you
know the people who self-identify as
Nazis being like Oh we love this this is
great we've got this Ultra nationalistic
Movie great and they're all cheering for
and they love it yes and then they're
doing that uh that that University of
California Santa Barbara is doing a
black only screen right
there could be some like CIA reverse
psychology here because if you look at a
lot of Mainline movies it's usually
going against the big evil government or
the multinational corporation or some
kind of evil villain that wants to
reduce the Earth's population for the
greater good I I think there might be
some kind of psyops here just again
speculating here totally out of nowhere
uh of them just being like you know
we're gonna put this in your head just
so you don't see it in real life
potentially I think I think there's
something to think about what are they
trying to put in your head
um or they're trying to to to to you
know put that satisfaction of rebellion
in your head so it doesn't come to
fruition in real life I'll give you an
example that's a V for Vendetta all the
movies are like this there's a show we
talked about this on the members only uh
The Matrix there's a there's a show
called The Good Fight
they did an episode I think it was the
finale where a character based on
milianopolis accuses Ron DeSantis by
name yeah of sexual assault and in the
show they are saying over and over again
Rhonda Santos accused and here's the guy
saying and I thought it was interesting
so we googled Ron DeSantis the good
fight and what do you find is so weird
Ronda Santos has many interviews where
he says I'm going to keep fighting the
good fight it just so happens a show
called The Good Fight comes out where
Rhonda Santos is accused of sexual
assault so what happens now when you
Google search Ronda said this the good
fight what a vile psyop you see posts
about sexual assault yeah and so maybe
it's all just one big coincidence but
man was that very perfect that wasn't
the craziest aspect of the entire
episode at the end Donald Trump runs to
be president of the United States and
the whole and this is before he
announced but the whole premise of the
episode is a terrorist attack by right
Wingers that are surrounding this black
lawyer firm there's 20 000 of them
outside and then they stage an attack on
them that's going to assassinate all of
them as they're shooting machine guns uh
into their building and that was
actually how happening in the show
that's that's the plot of the show the
plot of the show is that they're working
and these uh they wore the same outfits
as the Patriot front and there's 20 000
of them outside in Chicago causing riots
everywhere and then they stage an attack
where they uh you know make sure that
they block all the exits and then they
go on the roof and start shooting and
trying to assassinate all the children
and workers inside of this predominantly
all black lawyer here is supposed to be
taking place this is the last episode of
this series that came out of the and
it's it's the same it's the same episode
as the dissentice right I know are these
episodes Standalone I have no idea like
like I said is it an anthology show
where every episode is its own contained
little mini film I I think it's a series
that continues how do you how do you do
a season after that
I think that was their season finale I
know but like the start of the next
season is like so after like Civil War
started
I I think it's during a civil war anyway
my point is I think they do these things
in media uh because like there's that
famous line from Tina Fey where she said
I can see Russia from my house and then
what happened was a bunch of liberals
started saying Sarah Palin said she
could see Russia from her house no that
was Tina Fey Sarah Palin said actually
from the westernmost point of Alaska you
can see Russian territory we have to
negotiate with Russia because of the
straight and trade routes which is
actually an excellent point when you're
running for office and explaining that
you have to negotiate with Russia now
and then Tina Fey made fun of her in a
way that made no sense and now these
people believe that was the actual quote
so it's called the Primacy effect in
terms of whatever people see first is
what they tend to believe and when you
have mass media versus some news
individual news reports people believe
what they see first and tend to hold on
to that information even after it has
been corrected so one of the like really
I guess if you want to go along with all
of the beliefs about how bad fake news
is the real problem problem with fake
news such as it does exist is that it
doesn't matter there's several studies
on this it doesn't matter if you update
the news article people will remember
what they read first there's a competing
Theory called the recency effect that
people will remember whatever they heard
most recently however it has far less
robust support within the data the
Primacy effect is what we see very
consistency very consistently excuse me
that whenever people hear first or C
first sticks within their mind and
that's what they recall yep so is there
like an emotional bond because of that
first initial reaction it could there
could be an emotional aspect to it but
it's more that people are just taking in
information going okay this is
interesting or funny and if you make it
funny by the way it's called
instructional humor processing Theory
and what that finds is that if you're
trying to teach something teach
something to anybody make it funny
because it increases recall I love the
conspiracy theory that the government
funds movies to block conspiracy
theories like Men In Black for instance
the conspiracy theory is that Men In
Black are real so they make a movie
about it that's very exaggerated and
silly so that way if anyone ever says I
was visited by Men In Black they go like
the movie oh it's an episode of Stargate
sg1 like that Wormhole extreme right
right we actually had coronamic here
last week it was super cool we talked
about it so actually the episode of cast
Castle we did was Ian is convinced that
Koran is actually Jonas Quinn okay and
then that's that's basically the premise
where it's like it was funny because
when we were writing it I was like
that's actually an episode of Stargate
sg1 Wormhole extreme is a TV show
because like this yeah anyway and
Supernatural that was a plot line in
Supernatural where girl God was actually
sending Divine messages to some kooky
guy who wrote books about the actual
characters in the show and et cetera et
cetera so several shows have played with
this yeah you were telling us about a
lot of different theories that you were
studying and looking into before we
started the show what's one of the most
interesting study that you looked into
when it comes to psychology and our
current kind of kind of modern day
Society that's depressive I know I know
I like to ask these questions but my
favorite ones are mostly deal with
parasociality and studying of the
internet how people form fake
relationships that they feel are very
real with people online and this can
also include characters from media where
because we didn't evolve in a mediated
environment it's very difficult for
people to be able to delineate what is a
real interaction from what is a fake or
pseudo or parasocial interaction I love
that it's a whole broad field but I the
parasociality stuff and particularly now
when we have this constant interaction
with Twitter and people feel like they
know Donald Trump or they feel like they
know XYZ person that can have some very
harmful effects as well because well
what if your internet friend doesn't
respond in turn and there's tons of
research that's become very very popular
almost to the point of bringing it up is
probably trite at this point but a lot
of it uh referred to as family vloggers
and oh yeah like the concept of putting
your kid in danger because people think
they have a uh they have apparel social
relationship with your child who doesn't
know anything about it because the
concept of the internet is difficult
when you're five the idea of family
vlogging is horrifying to me because
you're putting the child out there and
exposing them to this constant Deluge of
media exposure before they're able to
form any kind of sense of self so or
consent they certainly can't consent
yeah yeah human beings aren't built to
be okay with social media they aren't
built to deal with so much attention so
much feedback so much comment so much
interactions all at once we used to be
small tribes that's what our body and
Men mental state is used to being and I
think this is one reason why we're
seeing such a huge increase of mental
health well the dopamine system is fried
the dopamine system it actually the
prolonged exposure to this kind of stuff
constantly day after day after day it
causes the parts of your brain that
produce and regulate dopamine to become
eventually unable to continue to produce
it at the same level so people become
just like any other addiction they
become addicted to the substance in this
case dopamine hit oh a like a retweet on
Twitter that kind of thing at some point
your brain cannot keep stimulating you
and feeding you the positive feedback
chemical that you want from it and then
it actually physically shrinks in size
your parts of your brain physically
shrink in size because it cannot keep
doing this but you also need more as
your body is less able to provide it can
you like inject dopamine I'm sure sure
like I mean like not like yeah does it
have the same effect I wouldn't I
haven't read any studies on that but I
would assume so I mean probably they'll
probably be like the next big thing it's
like a dreamer Chrome yeah you gotta get
the adrenochrome but I would with meta
The Proposal of meta and and that VR
stuff it's now up every single human
sense is being stimulated your dopamine
systems the whole dopaminergic system is
going to be fried for people and there's
going to be no way for them to get the
dopamine that they are so craving
because their own body can't produce it
anymore yeah and once your brain shrinks
sorry once your brain shrinks there's no
coming back it can yeah sure so like is
there a treatment for disconnect
ah no what's the same thing with any
other addiction more or less yeah well
also there's also very negative effects
especially when it comes to online
pornography and I think also with things
like Tick Tock are becoming more and
more popular this is kind of the larger
symptom of a society getting sicker and
sicker needing a quicker dopamine and
eating a quicker fix needing a quicker
stimulation uh just more and more uh
quicker quicker quicker faster faster
faster Tick Tock is completely exemplary
of that in that it's five to ten seconds
you get my stimulus and my output and
I'm good to go and now next next and it
never stops yeah where do you see this
going where where is society heading and
and where's the crash how does it look
like well in the the experiments they
did with rats which is always a good way
to start a sentence when you talk about
the future of society in the studies
that have been done with rats for
example they put a electrode in the
pleasure center of the brain in rats and
they gave them a little button and they
could just sit there and push the button
to stimulate the the pleasure center of
the brain they found that much as with
the rat Utopia experiment after a while
they stopped eating they stopped
reproducing they stopped having sex they
stopped cleaning themselves to the point
where they would just sit there and
press the button over and over again
until they'd essentially die so there's
the horrifying there's the really
horrifying potential future but uh let's
go meta right
thank goodness that company's failing
thank goodness they're losing so much
money don't go in the pods don't don't
put up please just imagine not knowing
what like accomplishment is what drives
us right getting more likes we're we're
like feeling a connection to something
happening but it really is just that
dopamine release there's two two forms
of pleasure that exist um it's eudemonia
and hedonia hedonia is pure physical
pleasure just a feeling good eudemonia
is a sense of meaningfulness and that's
what we're losing but so like I'm
imagining if there was a button that
could stimulate your brain you wouldn't
know why it was good you would just be
like this is great for some reason it
just keeps smashing the button it's
called Tick Tock yeah yeah it is that's
it but my point is on Tick Tock they do
they're like I'm seeing someone Dance
I'm seeing some social interaction yeah
but do they remember it when they get
consumed so much information so quickly
uh one one thing after another thing
after another thing do they really
remember it the recall is not not the
part of it that matters it's the instant
instantaneous dopaminergic stimulation
and again what's what's that's all the
hedonia the eudaemonia which are things
like again it's commonly called
meaningfulness of a feeling of
accomplishment a feeling of having done
something that's bigger than yourself I
when we look there's longitudinal
studies on human happiness we find
produces longitudinal human happiness is
not pleasure it's hedonia it's having
children it's having a home it's raising
a family it's having relationships
meaningful ones with other people and
that's not dopaminergically stimulating
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time